I know that they're gonna ask some tough
questions just like my family asked
Chris tough questions and I think that's
kind of where the nerves are already
done so who is it gonna be backup the
reserve divergent or what need the
bubbly nurse you know a lot of people
think the decision is obvious tonight
for back to the Chris well I talked to
host Chris Harrison today about that and
what brings the bachelor to tears in the
season finale so we actually see in the
promo Chris crying I love it what's that
about he goes back home Darlington and
he gets back with his family his parents
sisters are there and they meet the
women and they have very candid
conversations and his family they don't
hold punches and now let's get into the
big spoiler there are reports that Chris
is engaged to Whitney the fertility
nurse from Chicago
Whitney makes sense because Becca is
beyond nervous about moving to rural
Iowa where the finale takes place
tonight on ABC watch her get grilled by
Chris's mom you in California him in
Iowa tell me what you think of that I am
crazy about him
but I'm not at a point where I'm in love
with him if I say you have a choice here
you have two days to make a decision
here or it's going to end what would you
do that how accurate are the spoilers
have they been in two years past if
there are two more people in a room
especially in Hollywood it's gonna get
out even if you found out what happened
tonight I think you need to see what
goes on I mean you need to see what
happens with Chris's family you need to
see that the reaction and the rejection
and and everything that takes place and
the finale will break more news we're
hearing it could be announced that Chris
is joining Dancing with the Stars and
that the new bachelorette will be
revealed chris says it's between fan
fave kaitlyn they gave us lines like
this I know you are a farmer and
compiled the out of my field everything
and this waterproof mascara brick half
our staff is divided half of America
seems to be divided and there have been
heated I mean heated debates